everyone in Spain is a consumer of
energy including the founder and CEO of
ODF energiya Sergio Palmeiro I am from
the south of Spain non-civilian this
middle town in Spain not this
traditional intrapreneur territory
selection of people also so for me of
course especially to have an idea a
business idea and transform in a real
live really business so here had a
vision of how to better sell his energy
consumers in Spain by allowing them to
better manage their energy usage while
the newly deregulated Spanish energy
markets presented significant
opportunity for growth it also meant
significant challenges
[Music]
after getting the license for trading
energy in Spain in 2011 director has
changed the rules every month so it's
time that the relative move the rules
who had to move so we said that they
were going to do that is with that VPM -
yes before we decide to move all our
unfactual to the club because with this
grow is a problem to think about
provisioning of exactitude to prepare
them practically we don't want to have a
lot of technician a lot of IT people
their company of the energy norm of the
IP so the best way for us to adapt
technology we fracture to to our fitness
means was the cloud so we have to go to
the software and make changes to adapt
to the rules if you have a closed so
work is not possible or you dependent on
other people so if we have to be p.m.
integration layer we can develop this
chain in the way and incorporate to the
process quickly initial oh the energy ax
is a try a blazer using cloud-based
process management to help its customers
reduce energy costs it's a competitive
unjust so I'm very happy for us discover
how IBM Business Process manager and
cloud can help in your constantly
changing world
[Music]